[Musique]
tout simplement parce que ceux qui la
composent la composent sont déterminés
et motivés sincères dans leur volonté à
la fois faire bouger l'europe mal à
faire bouger en ayant le pragmatisme et
on se forgeant aussi l'état d'esprit sur
les réalités du terrain a tout bien
évidemment l'agriculture française ne
serait pas ce qu'elle est sans l'europe
et ne sera pas ce qu'elle sera sans
l'europe non plus par contre il faut que
l'europe reprennent un peu de courage
politique pour redonner un certain
nombre d'orientations et redonner à cap
une direction aux agricultrices et aux
agriculteurs de ce pays notamment mais
aussi aux agriculteurs européens
moi en tout cas je vais pousser pour que
puis-je à la fois basée aussi sur les
atouts que l'agriculture européenne peut
avoir sur la qualité de son alimentation
de son agriculture sur ce qu'elle peut
encore faire en matière d'environnement
et d'écologie
moi je pousserai ça pour faire en sorte
que l'agriculture redevienne un
véritable secteur stratégique
[Musique]
nous sommes pas inconscient sur les
nécessités de changer alors pas que le
modèle agricole d'ailleurs mais de
changer aussi notre manière de fuite de
vive notre manière de fonctionner notre
manière aussi voilà de traiter les
questions environnementales et dans
notre programme nous gérons cette
question écologique avec beaucoup
d'ambition mais avec surtout le
pragmatisme encore une fois nécessaire
qui permettra à la fois en relevant le
défi écologique de malgré tout maintenir
une certaine économie aussi sur les
territoires
[Musique]